[Music]
et has confirmed Ben's mystery woman is
37 year old Lyndsey sugars today Jen's
keeping quiet about Lindsay who is a
longtime producer at Saturday Night Live
a source tells et quote Ben and Lindsay
started dating after Ben engendered and
met a couple of years ago when he was
hosting SNL my source tells me that
Lindsay knows a Hollywood world she
knows what's expected Ben and how much
of the relationship has to be kept
private
it puts Ben at ease knowing that she
understands who he is today questions
are swirling about Lindsay's life before
Ben in 2010 she married former SNL
producer Kevin Miller and the source at
SNL tells us they thought Lindsay was
still married when their season ended in
May Lindsay has a four-year-old daughter
from that marriage but sources can't
confirm if she's meant Ben's kids yet
saying only quote Ben is still all about
his children first he always will be Ben
and Jen cared deeply for their families
my source tells me that if Lindsay meets
the kids you can be sure that the
situation will be dealt with very
delicately
[Music]
you